ramadan ist herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einem neuen video von wie ihr
seht schon anders hintergrund ziehe dass
ich mich wieder bei meinen eltern
befindet zu hause behalten kinderzimmer
was sie noch um lag ist nämlich diese
fette box voll mit kinderfotos wir
eventuell das habe ich vor einiger zeit
mit meiner mutter ein buch geschrieben
in dem wir verschiedene story zu
gewissen kindheits bildern zu mir
erzählt haben und deswegen stehen diese
ganzen boxen mit den ganzen
kinderbildern familie noch in meinem
zimmer und ich habe mir gedacht hey im
buch sind ja nicht alle von diesen zehn
tausenden bildern drin ich könnte ja
einfach immer nachschauen welche bilder
wir nicht ins buch reingepackt haben wo
euch allerdings trotzdem entweder eine
geschichte zu erzählen kann oder die
einfach nur hart peinlich sind und das
sind eigentlich so gut wie alle bei
diesem bild hier bin ich mir
hundertprozentig sicher ob es vielleicht
doch im buch drin ist und zwar bin dort
ich mit einem koffer und einem ich
glaube das ist ein alter porsche oder so
und wir stehen darum das ist in der
schweiz irgendwo es sieht so aus als
müsste ich gleich zu einem business
meeting und steigt jetzt gerade in
meinen sportwagen und vereine zu einem
kunden beim nächsten vortrag ich keine
ahnung was sie genau gerade vor sich
geht aber da bin auf jeden fall ich und
streiche irgendwie so ein küken will man
die chance fokussieren streichelt da
irgend so ein küken ich habe keine
ahnung wo das herkommt also ich bin der
hier in dem gelben pulli mit diesem
komischen topf schnitte auf dem kopf
also ich habe wirklich überhaupt keine
ahnung was da gerade vor sich geht da
war ich drei jahre alt also vielleicht
macht dich schicken sehr gern dass hier
auf dem foto sind mein cousin und ich
ich fokussiert dass wir eben ganz kurz
und zwar ausgesucht weil ich da
irgendwie den leuten käse gebracht habe
die an einem tisch saßen und ich weiß
also erstens ich hasse käse und zweitens
was hatte ich da an freunde irgendwie so
einen schwarzen pullover aber dann noch
eine weiße latzhose wenn ich irgendwann
kinder haben sollte werde ich auf jeden
fall nicht so anziehen wie ich früher
dabei ist von meiner eltern angezogen
wurde übrigens sorry für meine haare
aber egal wie oft sich die hoch mache
die fallen immer wieder runter muss ich
zum friseur und ein bisschen volumen
rausnehmen lassen auf diesem foto hier
bin ich am strand allerdings nicht
normal am strand liegt darum und bräune
mich oder so sondern irgendwie sieht so
aus als würde ich gerade versuchen eine
liegestütze zu machen
und irgendwie ja krieg ich glaube ich
nicht so ganz hin was hier gerade
passiert weiß nicht ganz genau ich weiß
nur dass wir vorne nauheimer steht und
nicht gerade aussteigen muss und
deswegen werden wir ein bisschen traurig
bin weil ich mag autos auf diesem foto
hier sehen sie mich an mein erstes
richtiges lego meisterwerk da wurde auf
jeden fall der grundstein für eine
minecraft karriere gelegt da ja da
brauche ich glaube ich nichts mehr zu
sagen auf dem foto hier drücke ich
irgendwie also ihr seht schon da bin ich
strecke meine bauhaus und werke die
leute da an hey ich war ein toller
freund glaube ich früher vier versuche
ich glaube ich irgendwie tief zu zeigen
habe aber irgendwie nur einen finger
gerade in der luft
meine softbox hat gerade den geist
aufgegeben auf dem foto sehe ich
eigentlich ganz gut aus finde ich das
war 2001 also da war ich fünf jahre alt
aber typisch luca so sah das in dem
moment aus den 50 und später sah ich so
aus und hatte irgendwie eine spinne wird
sich auf dem kopf keine ahnung was auf
dem foto hier abging aber es sieht so
aus als wenn ich gerade aus einer
schlägerei kommen würde beziehungsweise
nahm ich blöd angemacht hat und ich
sagen würde direkt an einer das bin ich
mit meiner wundervollen ersten schultüte
wieso ersten schultüte man kriegt doch
noch einen ganzen leben
sorry freunde werden jetzt den
krankhaften leichter wenn ich gesund
werden soll ich weiß nicht was auf dem
foto hier gerade abgeben aber es sieht
so ein bisschen so aus als wenn ich
gerade von einer stickerei kommen würde
und irgendwie bin ich kann alles mit
schlägereien hier sieht auf jeden fall
so aus als hätte ich gerade irgendwie
sport gemacht in meinem tanktop mit
ernie und bert drauf auf jeden fall
werde ich kein sport macht oder nicht
geboxt hat oder irgendwie so und dann ja
ab zum nächsten foto könig luca steht
auf seinem podest
eine rutsche und grüßt seiner ganzen
untertanen dass hier bei uns im früheren
haus im wohnzimmer und zwar habe ich
dort eine
kartbahn oder irgend so eine autobahn
oder so hier gebaut mit all meinen
freunden freunde da ich mit meinen
freunden hier hatte ich geburtstag und
wurde irgendwie geweckt gerade und hatte
irgendwie gar keinen bock drauf und
irgendwie sie zu hause werde ich am
vorabend kraft laufen gewesen und habe
jetzt den übelsten kater das waren jetzt
auf jeden fall einige bilder die ich
noch herumliegen hatte ich glaube ein
oder zwei von denen waren tatsächlich im
buch drin hier findet ein link für das
buch in der beschreibung ich dachte
vielleicht wäre es ganz interessant weil
so ein paar peinliche bilder auszusuchen
oder irgendwelche sachen die irgendwie
lustig aussehen haben ich wollte das
video heute eigentlich zusammen mit
meiner mutter machen dass sie noch sagt
was wirklich auf den in den bestimmten
situationen passiert ist allerdings ihr
kennt das mütter die haben unendlich
viele termine also sie hat heute
wirklich keine zeit weil sie noch mit
oma und opa irgendwie was machen musst
du uns so aber es natürlich auch
vollkommen in ordnung deswegen habt ihr
heute du mich gesehen obwohl das er
eigentlich nur scheiße ist wenn man mich
sieht das was jetzt hier vom bio das war
es jetzt hier vom video hier können
jetzt jemand den kanal abonnieren oder
hier unten meinen job aus checken jetzt
findet ihr zwei andere videos und wenn
ihr schon abonnent seid könnt ihr auf
die glocke klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]